Hi everyone, I'm Shay Mitchell and today, I'm here shooting for People Magazine's shoot.
What makes me feel most beautiful is probably when I get home from the gym,...
...or any form of workout actually.
It clears up my mind, and my body feels good and strong,...
...and there's just a different kind of confidence and happiness.
One of my favorite beauty tips is from my mom...
...and her thing to me was always moisturize, moisturize, moisturize.
And then, she added in the coconut oil.
And my mom being from the Philippines,...
...they use a lot of that over there for their hair and for their skin.
So if you have some coconut oil, that's my beauty trick.
Moisturize, moisturize, moisturize.
Working with three other girls,...
...everybody always asks what other tips do you pick out from the other girls.
And even though I play this athletic character on the show, outside of it...
...I'm probably the girliest; no, I am.
I'm always kind of sending out numbers back and forth...
...and I'm like try this person, try this person, I just got my nails done.
I'm kind of the beauty tipster for that, out of our little group.